Wagner il y a eu un changement de plan
mais j'ai pas encore eu l'occasion
d'enquêter sur le cycle respiratoire des
algues alors vous devez faire vite pour
être dans
les temps si le découvre il pourrait
détruire les échantillons
commandant Wagner qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est notre nouveau plan de vol pour
demain
il y a une étrange masse de brouillard
dans l'hémisphère nord et personne ne
sait ce que c'est le contrôle le seul
nous a donné son feu vert
vous êtes prêts
le Beacon a fait ça deux brûler
[Applaudissements]
docteur crillot nous devons parler des
algues est-ce que la symbiose
respiratoire fonctionne ou non ils sont
tous morts
est toxique
combien de temps nous pouvons rester ici
[Musique]
commande dans Wagner à contrôle au sol
vous me recevez
tu voudrais vieillir ici ne jamais avoir
la terre tu appelles ça une vie toi en
tout cas ça en est une
nous sommes un groupe
s'il vous plaît
si on pouvait acheminer tes algues
là-bas ça pourrait les sauver
on a une responsabilité morale ma seule
responsabilité morale est de te garer
toi et toi en V ça s'arrête là et si
c'était les dernières personnes sur
terre c'est bien plus important que nous
ne me dis pas qu'on les perds maintenant
tu touches pas ça
j'ai besoin de ton CO2
[Musique]
il n'y a aucune honte de vouloir prendre
soin de ta propre vie en a
[Musique]